vlog late night just jam and some stuff
but it's interesting that just show the
wine scene real quick - there you go you
come right back to this 2018 looking to
do this format much more often on my
podcast get three to four interesting
friends together drink some wine talk
some [ __ ] this is a throwback to the
first episode in case you missed it I
hope you enjoy it the first episode of
brown paper bag 2018 huge year for brown
paper bags everybody this is Gary
Vaynerchuk and this is a new I'm
definitely gonna do this more than once
but maybe it won't be a 2 thing thing
ever but I doubt it I think this could
become a new standard as many of you
know who are listening I grew up in the
wine world and I've been trying to
figure out ways to spend more time in it
I miss it in a lot of ways with all the
stuff I've been doing in tech and
entrepreneurship and so as my podcast
continues to evolve in December we
rebranded it to the gary vee audio
experience which allowed me to do a lot
more things with it obviously there's
keynotes there's original content that
i'm making for some rants but this one
is completely straight to podcast it's
something I'm calling brown bags so this
is episode 1 brown bags within the Gary
Vee audio experience and this comes from
the favorite thing that ever happened
while I was in the wine world for the
first kind of 20 years of my
professional life which is when you
really get nerdy about wine you start
getting to a place where you're trying
to figure out how good you are at it and
one of the ways to do that is to taste
wines blind meaning there's blind where
you kind of knew what the wines were and
you put them in a brown paper bag or tin
foil which we have here set up and then
you're trying to guess them or analyze
them or there's double blind which is my
favorite which is you literally don't
know what the wines are and they're in
brown paper bags or tin foil and so I've
invited three of my friends to join me
and that's gonna be the format between
three or four people each episode
different buddies from around the world
from different walks of life and I'll
introduce these beautiful and wonderful
people in two seconds and we will
literally do the following the format of
this show is we're going to taste the
wines we're gonna
try to tell ourselves whether we like it
you know once in a while we bring in a
real professional like Andre here who
I'll introduce in a minute maybe we'll
even get a little bit deeper and really
challenge ourselves and probably get
exposed or sometimes show amazing skills
uh and then kind of talk also about
current events things in the business
world or just the relationship I have
with these wonderful individuals so
before anything else I would love to get
your feedback on this format so be very
aggressive on Twitter with with the
feedback put a feedback brown bags
hashtag feedback brown bags I'll search
it that way
I'd love to see what you guys think and
so let's do this let's start introducing
why don't we start with you America hi
everyone I'm Mary Kate McGrath I'm the
editor in chief of pure Wow which is a
digital media company we write about all
things for women's lifestyle including
wine so I'm very excited that Gary just
handed me a very heavy pour or something
white yes that's right now very heavy
handed can we even say that it's before
lunch it's 10:00 in the morning so this
is actually my second glass today you
drank much of wine right yeah before
10:00 a.m.
like a big percentage of the wine that
you've consumed in your life prior to
10:00 a.m.
absolutely add in the fact that once
it's 12:01 it's the next day the
majority wine thing I would say about 60
or 70 percent yeah what can you do you
also did not mention that I bought pure
Wow in January it's actually it's
actually gary after this podcast all
right it's done I just did it good all
right um hi I'm Erin Heatherton and I
you may know me for my work for with
Victoria's Secret and supports
Illustrated and maybe in the future for
you know getting drunk on the show this
morning and so talk tell everybody
I know a lot of people are listening
like me or sports fans I'm fascinated by
your true love of sports give a little
bit of like the
content or some stuff you've been doing
in that world because I'm intrigued by
that yes so I was I mean my parents are
married because of sports until they do
like so I i yes sports play just played
a huge role in my life I always I played
basketball everyday I ran track and you
know those those experiences shaped Who
I am and and they were the most kind of
rewarding and built my confidence and
kind of like you know I think everything
I bring to the table in the modeling
world came from being a competitive
athlete and having that having that
mobility and kind of just it's being a
model is a lot like being an athlete
because you're just you got to perform
with your body and it's just you know
and if you got to play good you're not
playing so I kind of yeah that shaped me
and also I kind of figured at you know
it's certain at a certain point you know
I for five years I did high fashion so I
did you know five years of Fashion
Week's it's like ten fashion weeks and
I've been around all these you know I
was plucked at kind of out of Chicago
and into New York into this fashion
world and I wasn't involved in growing
up and I got to a certain point where
I'm like you know there's nothing wrong
I don't dislike anyone in fashion but
being at a party with a bunch of people
that love fashion I'm not really that I
realized I'm just not that into fashion
I want to I would rather spend my time
being around people who enjoy sports
because I understand those people those
people are those are my people yeah and
so I kind of took I I realized that I'm
like I'm gonna take myself from this
corner of like I always thought it
really kind of there's like four
frozen-yogurt stands in one corner
they're all just like I'm just gonna
take myself and go somewhere else and
see what I can achieve and I could be
around people that are people that I can
feel more comfortable around you know
what I'm saying that's what sports do
and that's what sports it for me so I
started working with the Northwest and
that was a great he never worked with a
model before and I was their spokesmodel
for two years and most likely continuing
got to do amazing things to like throw
you know opening pitches the Cubs and
Mets games and you know just travel
around go to the Super Bowl talk to
people you know people that are involved
in the sports world are incredible
I think that there's just this true I
mean I don't want to I'm going on a
sports rant excuse me okay because my
fans know I love to do that
how devastated are you that Jimmy Butler
is now in Minnesota not in Chicago
dude Jimmy Butler's my boy you're
crushed yes I'm so crushed I hit him up
on Twitter and I produced this horse
game with him through Sports Illustrated
and he is I just was what like that that
season like he captivated me and I was
just like I mean I've it was since you
know Michael Jordan and I never really
had some beautiful were throwing that
name around here I hate him with all my
heart
you don't like Jimmy no no Jimmy's fine
ish but I hate Michael Jordan oh really
oh my god please tell me I love devices
fan and I hate Michael Jordan that's a
perfect segue Andre yeah yo yo this is
Andre Mack aka Mouton de waar I make
wine from the Pacific Northwest and I'm
excited to be here today
so Andre I mean that listen let's get a
little bit D here you're the real wine
guy here I I played one once in a while
but like you were why don't you give us
a two-minute story of like your rise to
fame because we met a long time ago you
know when I thought of this you know
concept your name bubbled to the Tippie
time you know I interacted with mmm
hundreds of thousands of wine people but
you were at number one on the list of
what I want history no today so tell
everybody yeah now so my background is
restaurants I just a summer really for
for many years but we've got the first
wine poured these are all blind wines
the first one is a white wine we've
established that we're gonna let Andre
tell his thing but like I could see that
Aaron was like ready to like it yourself
you guys can smell it but do not drink
yet we're gonna get into the sniffy
sniff and the first taste in a minute
place team we need Andre go ahead no no
so I started in restaurants my
background was in restaurants was a
sommelier for many years I started in
Texas of all places and made my way to
the French Laundry in California worked
for chef Kyle Thomas Keller
then I moved to New York uncited scene
in 2004 to be the opening opening
sommelier for the sister restaurant per
se and that's where I met Gary Gary came
in with a group of purveyors and a
friend and I was like who the [ __ ] is
this guy like he just kept chirping and
I was like I'd like this guy like I had
never heard of them and then like I
think he went to the bathroom and John
Lee in any case knock now do this dude
sells the most [ __ ] wine on the
internet I was like that guy's like that
dude and we we quickly became friends
and but anyways that that's kind of my
rise I've been in New York ever since I
left the restaurant business in 2007
wanting to continue my education about
wine and I felt the only way to do that
was to make my own so we make about
40,000 cases now and 47 states 22
countries
and what's the biggest how many
different SKUs do we have about like 13
different SKUs but we're skew heavy for
those our most popular wine is called
other people's Pinot I'm sure you've
seen it it's got a big old white and
black OPP on the front you throw a lot
of hip-hop into your into your wine
names and things that nature right yep
absolutely I mean you know I'm just a
kid who I grew up on hip hop and I just
happened to fall in love with wine and I
just kept thinking why not be able to
put those two things together I felt
like every person I talked to who in the
one who was in the wine business always
got the hip hop references we're always
singing those songs you have you uh have
you you know as a Texas boy I feel like
Scarface hasn't entered any of your
labels just yet don't you think it's a
little disrespectful and can can we
please address that with one of your
next cuvee maybe maybe we'll do it
subtly but yeah they were wrong they
were wrong before this caucus they were
really raw I don't know if they're
really ready for that I got tentatively
I had a wine called ill 9 so my get the
kibosh kibosh what the alcohol tabacco
world I think
more my wife or Scottie I know what that
is like like yeah alright established
we've established the four of us let's
go into the first wine Andre I'm gonna
let you take it away
what would should everybody be doing at
this point oh wow you should be actually
looking at the color color can tell you
a lot of different things but we have a
brown background so maybe you want to
hold it over the rug or maybe a white
background you just want to kind of look
at the wine I mean we get points for
naming the color of the wine so it's
white let's establish some rules here we
don't need to guess what this is or what
you have it where I want to take it for
all four of us even for us like we don't
think guess where what regions is from
what vintage we don't need to at this
point Andre it must be fun for you as
well we grew up in the wine world when
it wasn't cultural now because of
Netflix and all these documentaries
everybody if you also has seen some or
or this that or the other things so even
though Andre very much has those
capabilities and I'm sure guests that I
have on brown bags will have those
capabilities that is not really where
I'm looking to take it or I'm looking to
take it is do you like it what does it
taste like
and how maybe how much do you think it
costs would be cool can do me a favor
Trouty under your in the background I
don't know what the wines are either I
know Brandon picked them from wine
library can you get him to text you what
the wines are and maybe like maybe the
current mainstream scores and the price
point just so when we have the unveil
because I'm totally not prepared for
this
so can look guess like our you can guess
anything you want I would like to not
like without telling us like I want to
know if we know it's like a Syrah or a
Pinot I promise you it's not because no
I because you know anchoring yes no no
don't worry
so let's simply snip first for anybody
who watched Wine Library TV
I call it sniffy sniffy because I wanted
to be funny and wanted to be memorable
but what I really wanted was you know
wine let me TV it'll be interesting I'll
actually ask you your perspective from
Wine Library TV it was so important to
me to trick America at scale into a
couple things that I thought mattered
which is one trust your own palate
forget about what Andre and
I say like we don't get nervous about
our point of view on sushi or a
cheeseburger but with wine we're always
looking at the person that knows the
most and we have to succumb to his or
her point of view
I hated that I'd like to change that
that was a big goal of mine and number
two we need to smell wine more like you
guys cannot imagine how much more you
will enjoy the wine if you smell it so
let's get the snippy snip now mary-kate
I don't want you to be polite or pure
while we here I want your schnoz there
you go all the way in yeah yes well I
like swirling you know so yeah you want
to aerate the wine I you know and what
Gary's talking about most people don't
smell the wine ninety percent of taste
is smell Yeah right think about like
when you're a kid and you pinched her
nose because something you didn't want
to eat your asparagus or whatever it was
right kind of the same thing so you want
to actually slightly crack your mouth
I'm getting a little nerdy here Gary I'm
sorry you want to crack your mouth a
little bit and you want to inhale
through your nose and exhale through
your mouth right and that opens up with
your olfactory senses so you get like
this better sense of you want to smell
what you just say I've never smelled
like that before in my life yeah I just
just blew my mind
getting on the nose like what are we
tasting here can you hear me smell yeah
I know you drank and that's fine too
like for me a melon and honeydew thing
is coming through on the nose good way
that right we get a little bit of canned
asparagus like slightly like when you
first open it up not that that's a bad
thing or a good thing my mom I guess our
mom but now I shouldn't go to a good
solid like you know like like fresh food
for me okay Brooke lonely no fear
you know this my first job out of
college I was a whisky editor and I was
a 22 year old girl who had never drank
whiskey before in her life and I'd got
the job as to this job sounds like a
real [ __ ] fun establish no I had a
very smart whiskey person yes but I
would have to go into tastings and Andre
this is what I always wanted to call
[ __ ] on people because they'd be
like oh I smell the pizza that I love
you're in you know Scotland in 1901 and
we're like what I smell alcohol like
correct and that's exactly yeah and that
and that's what I smelled at the
beginning when I first started it was
like all I smell is alcoholic I mean how
can you get any of those things out of
that so but canned asparagus this really
harkens you back to I can't but these
are all moments right like you can smell
things it's supposed to take you back
and when I tell people when you smell
wine don't talk about what it makes you
think about look like he was famous for
saying this is like big league chew
yeah well you know it's like obviously
nice like that but like that's what it
reminded of when you open up that pouch
yeah we had your boys got in that story
it's it's about memories like someone's
like hey this one reminds me of my
grandfather and you're like so what
about your grandfather yeah I just sit
on his lap and he would smoke a cigar ah
right like that's the CNR you're
smelling the oak on the wine right so I
think it's just more about memories it's
like when you smell something I would
add on that like Andres point like what
really broke me out I thought with my
Lamberty be is that I really just talked
about I remember being scared to being
called out in a blind tasting I was in
the wine world
mhm it wasn't like I was trying to be a
comedian or doing a stick so I remember
being fearful of people giving me a
glass of wine and saying what do you
smell or what do you think and so I was
like look I need to go is true for
everybody who's listening in the same
way I kind of call it like I see it
stuff I did that for wine in that I used
big league chew or the way a racquet
ball smelled to me or anything else
because I knew that if I smelt it again
I could recall it and so how the nuances
are there as they are in coffee and tea
and other alcohols Brown Goods the
flavors are there
I think to Andres point and to your
point actually I apologize there was a
lot of adjectives and descriptors that
were established by the wine world that
everybody kept rinsing and repeating and
I feel like we forced our ways into it
whereas now I think with the
democratization of Instagram and
personalities and bloggers and what I
started with Wine Library TV now that
there aren't four or five people that
control everything anymore
there's been more freedom in the
descriptors absolutely I think that's
how we prescribe lines is banging right
you're like that one is banging oh wow
okay it also just did monetization of
like the entry of wine to the fact that
you have an OPP I mean like that didn't
exist
no years ago alright enough [ __ ]
let's drink this alright how do you
drink it okay I'm so I love technical
stuff like this yeah yeah yeah you just
want to you know sip it maybe pull in
some air into your mouth who you want to
gargle it you can gargle it all those
things make a difference like some
people swish it around in their mouth
push it through the front part of their
teeth you know that all those different
things can tell people something it's a
really really really great errand to
like make sure it hits as much of your
tongue as possible so I that like that
is something that you should really pick
yeah you like that part of Zini
like hey smell I smell differently today
it tasted differently today right the
reason you probably said Ziggy's you
probably got more wine into the back of
your tongue which is gonna kick that in
and most people never get oh wow my aunt
my face I'm just like wow yeah wine
drinking the other body part no it just
was a powerful feeling it was really
good news rad like so to me the one
thing that for everybody who's listening
that I highly recommend is getting the
tasting wine in two ways one if you're
like listening along right now just
taste your wine just drink it in a way
you normally do and then to swish it
around and let it hit different parts
you will be stunned by how different it
tastes will be ironic is for most people
the second way usually will not be as
because the acidity and the tannins
depending on a red or white wine will be
more accentuated when it hits more of
your mouth and you won't like that
bitterness or acid as much now and it'll
become for a lot of people less
flavorful I found that with this though
like that feeling balanced it like that
you know you liked it or this is great
what nyla nobody say what they think oh
my god I've just jumped in the gun
looking bows are gonna thanks for
cutting move on in a minute like gather
your thoughts on this wine we think
about sheet sheets or something right
yeah I mean there's only five wines if
your memories not take out your phone
I'm gonna pour the second wine Andre yes
what's been going on in the wine world
like what's the real kind of what's a
trend or to that for somebody like me
that's not in it day in and day out
anymore
has emerged in the last couple years got
it lots more sparkling wine from America
it's not you yeah so you're starting to
see a lot more of that definitely made
in like different fashions like methods
Shep and Waze but you also have stuff
that's happening you know Pat net style
so you have a lot of that kind of stuff
going on lawar value of varietals are
pretty hot here domestically or valleys
my favorite that's yeah that's what I
look for well you mean Sancerre just
flora Valley but like Sancerre yeah as
Chablis is as that's burgundy is it yeah
really
look at my hair
absolutely rose' is something that's
that's white-hot right now that's insane
yeah ten years ago I couldn't sell
rosette movie if like it came with free
money now it's like literally culture
yeah well and it's just interesting to
be on that beat you know we started
making rosy in 2009 and taking it out to
places across the country people are
like yeah whatever like Las Vegas like
it's hot as [ __ ] there and people are
like nope because people didn't want to
be confused with drinking white
zinfandel that's right that was a halo
that sat over it forever that white
zinfandel
it was $2.00 and it was sweet and it was
garbage grandmother's drank it and
nobody wanted to be associated with it
it came in like jugs yep
and so now it's changed you know I'm
like I'm in Minnesota and someone's like
hey I'm gonna take you to the shop that
has you know the most rows a and you
walk in and last year they had like a
table with five of them on it now they
have two tables full right so it's it's
definitely a genre that's grown and I
think just now more it's more part of
popular culture of celebrities playing
in the field which what do Pratt
Angelina when they were together then
but then but then Anna fat Jewish like
so it mine is really becoming more part
of American culture and not I'm excited
about you know I mean I'm excited about
all of it but I see a lot of that kind
of stuff happening that you know that
the competition is a lot stiffer now
right there's a lot more people starting
out like I did at the beginning right
you know just like doing whatever they
can you know I started it was like
[ __ ] couch surfing like wherever at
free or extended terms is where you know
I kind of hung my hat but you're
starting to see lots of small stuff
everywhere you know what I mean like
just you know small producers or small
producers I mean we live in here in New
York you can sell anything
yep cuz but like even just across the
country I mean even the rise of natural
wine domestic and foreign has really
really hit New York hard and Strickling
out into other states but you definitely
see that but on the production side I
would say you've seen a lot more
sparkling wine America versus what are
your readers like when it comes to wine
what's working like what are people
paying attention to what are some of
those more viral stories well definitely
Rosie and Rowe
saying like any kind of fast that they
can find it so it's rosette cocktails
it's froze a it's frozen rose a but wine
is more like a lifestyle to look for
them so wine to pair with your book club
wine to pair when it's just yourself
wine to pair with foods wine to pair the
vents holidays I mean it really is they
see it lifestyle first and which I love
because then it means they're drinking
more of it but it's it's more the
lifestyle aspect first like they're not
nerding out they're not studying it
they're not anything yeah they're not
trying to figure out every nuance sure
and like standard price points region
that comes into play but really more
like how to serve it and where and when
to serve it really is like fascinating I
love that this this has a totally
different nose in the first wine this is
also a white wine my see really smell
like a little bit of vanilla yeah
there's a ton of vanilla do you smell
that
mm-hmm you got that Trouty over there
and the police receipts over there you
would meet with your rivalry I really
hope you guys survive no there's a ton
of vanilla bean going on all right let's
give it a whirl I'm spinning the wine
the the restaurant you're drinking it
directly to the face I feel like we're
gonna talk a little bit about the wines
now cup so let's do that I don't want to
sway opinions below well Mary Kate we'll
start with you so we're not saying what
we'd like better we're just talking
about this we're talking about this
specific wine this white wine so is it
fresh is it heavy I love it you hate it
I let me start writing do not like the
first wine I hated their first one okay
it reminded me on drank grandmother not
that choice stirs but off straight up
it's okay now remember we're lasers why
are this one for source why just for
everybody at home Aaron first wine loved
it yeah I like oyster
that's why what about the wine yeah but
it's like a kind of a wine that you
haven't Mary's fish cabin yes nice that
you understand so so one thing for
everybody who's into wine a little bit
we're tasting these wines at room
temperature and so white wines get
really exposed if I learn white wines
get very exposed when they're at room
temperature because the the cold is not
hiding it I always called it like you
know kind of like the high school beer
rule like when you're drinking natty
light or Milwaukee's best you know it
just Marcus's favorite the Beast like
you get it as cold as [ __ ] possible
because you don't want to taste it right
so one of the reasons I've always tasted
white wine at room temperature is I
actually wanted to taste it because if
you get this ice if why number one was
dead
ice cold we'd like yeah okay cool I
really was rushing I wish you'd explain
this before because I just thought that
this was like a beep like wine tasting
no just gave you guys approaches that
feels real [ __ ] I like that so much
yeah you yeah hide flaws in wine by cold
it's like chilling them and making them
cold air um that first pull line is like
over make up individuals you can hide
anything got it yeah that's why my drink
is with ice cubes yeah yeah I get it
yeah had a sparkling wine that they they
promoted as with games right and has it
done well I haven't seen it in the
market the only way I've seen it because
my boy was one of them yeah that was
going around with it yeah what do you
think about all the wines and cans and
like new formats of delivery I'm so
Underwood yeah I like that that Rosana
can and are gonna like actually just
coming out with think July 13th are
coming out with yes right yeah that
sister's birthday happy birthday
good thanks yeah yeah yeah your wife
yeah yeah no my wife's name is Liz my
sister's name is Liz I just changed my
name
you know what one day Candice is great
you know I think it's I think it you
know is it for everybody I think you you
know one is this big long train that you
can get on at any time that you want get
on and off so if you're into wine and a
can I think I think it's great I like
the stuff from Underwood I think it's
great I think it gets really great out
right yeah but the great out is the wine
yes are you supposed to drink it in they
can you don't have to know and actually
that's that's opposed to what anything
across them in brown bags episode one
you want to [ __ ] funnel that wine
right now yeah funnily that's right you
want to drink it out of a like like
enough like like no but this is real no
we do this with wine and we don't do
this with everything it tastes different
in a canvas that's Mike we know man it
was good I like new experiences though I
like I like breaking the rules and it's
like this is weird but it's dangerous
though right
because that's a half bottle of wine and
people drink it like beer trust me I'm
the most American after I can't apply
yeah yeah but but I just think if you
want it you can shoot
okay so again I haven't thrown up in a
while but yeah my god let's get serious
here let's turn up round back there we
go here we go we're only going to we got
three more to go
mary-kate what is the last time that you
threw up like hungover third alright
yeah not like you ate a weird audience
as Gary knows and most of the team here
now knows I do like to go out and have a
good time so it and I do have two
children to listen essentially cuz I'll
be popular with them because I'm skewing
younger but for now they're very young I
think they won't hear this charlie yes
we're worried about Charlie's
entrepreneurial skills um yeah
definitely this past year I definitely
you threw up
oh for sure for sure I was so proud of
you for sure
I like I don't say no to a fun time yeah
for sure
oh my gosh it's so embarrassing I
complied in the last 365 days you threw
up from too much alcohol consumption
sure five times
yeah
going on my best friend right now and
see what the exact date was she knows
Anna that's pretty bizarre you
I don't bomb no bomb no I don't know I'm
Irish yeah I didn't know that throwing
up was now called vom but I'm pretty
fired up about that now we all know I've
contributed something today
yes opinions are being contributed Aaron
what do you think about wine number two
why number two this is we are we sharing
as we go and yes we're sharing as we go
I change the rules we're gonna mom our
opinions though I mean I I rarely mean a
wine I don't don't
I mean compared this to wine um I mean
I'm kind of upset that everyone's like
hating on the first one dobe cuz I like
the first one it may be a pioneer we may
unveil it and like one of the ladies in
the white wine today yeah what do you
what do you think about this wine I
think it's alright I think that is it
too soft do you feel like the subtleties
compared to wine number one and that
makes it a little boring for you cuz I
see a boring face it's like spicy like I
said I forgot I smelled it there's
nothing spicier about this one than the
first one and I like even coffee - I
like things like I like instant coffee
and Dunkin Donuts like that do you know
what I mean there's like I don't know if
it's like acidic I like when I asked for
wine I asked from inner inner ality okay
Andre wine number 2
wine number 2 vanilla slightly oaky like
a man you know I think it has this place
it's pretty decent but you seem bored by
it yeah you know I'm not
I found why number one maybe to be a
little bit more interesting because it
was funky right yeah because it wasn't
yeah as this thing this wine seems a
little bit more yep technical and
laboratory made yeah that way where the
other wines seem to have like a Bosch
right you know some funk to it
understood definitely like this one
better this is more my jam this feels
like ladies who lunch white wine like
this this gets the job done or consumed
in mass quantities yeah one that's
interesting that you say that about one
because I thought at first it was swell
but now
I do a whole bit more respect that you
say that like I like the vanillin
sentiment of this this is an easy
drinking white but now I'm super curious
because maybe you're right maybe one has
a nuance there that that but you know
Gary served it at like warm ass
temperature but maybe it may be chilled
maybe out here because right now all the
wines that taste hot you're the ample
that alcohol is really amplified right
huh so that's what we're tasting right
and you so for me the good news is I
have more self-esteem than me
I really love wine number two and don't
like wine number one I wasn't persuaded
by Andres charm like Mary Kay was a very
big fan of wine number two I feel like
it's interesting where you're coming I'm
losing your back go in and see what
carries I think what's really
interesting to me is as you were talking
cuz I respect your palate so much of
like huh cuz for me number two why
number two is so well-balanced and is it
so integrated fruit acidity
structure-wise or is it boring like this
is where it gets sometimes super
interesting with wines when it's so you
know and you said it this is why this is
fun it doesn't matter what angle you
come from all of us were wildly
interestingly saying the same thing you
said it in your way like like you like
the radness of wine number one this the
spiciness you were like basically trying
to Erin articulate your thoughts on it
but basically what you were saying is
it's seamless and either boring or clean
you were saying that and you said Mary
Kate you were saying it's you know it
gets the job done people will like it
because what you were reacting to was
that seamlessness
nothing was out of whack there wasn't
anything too aggressive and that either
means that it's a boring-ass wine that
is too technical and it's funny how you
you broke it down and it's kind of like
a cliche wine that like is on
supermarket shelves at Albertsons and
everybody can like it or it means it's
like a white Burgundy like wine or
producer that's making a seamless
integration now I'm excited to see what
why number two is I have a crash
another question let's go you're gonna
go to wine number three I have a
question about about boring wine versus
exciting wine yes I see I don't like
Cabernet is that what people is that is
it is it just because it's not boring
it's like why don't you like it because
it's so much it's saying powerful yeah
and and maybe like it just has a lot
happening it's like heavy yeah like I
don't like Kevin I don't know why people
are so white so popular but maybe
they're bored by Pinos but you know I
think also like Cabernet nu or Cabernet
like you know it and when he needs new
world Cabernet for everybody listening
oh no no worries you doing your thing
that's what I'm here for
he's talking about that Napa Valley
Cabernet is like not the Cabernet based
wines from Bordeaux or even Tuscany like
new world Cabernets are gonna have a lot
of fruit - there's a silver oaks and the
que mice's and the harlan's that a lot
of you know if you're into wine scope
keep going ya know but like the whole
factors like coming new to wine like
it's made from grapes right it's made
from fruit you know most people
association why doesn't it taste sweet
why does it why does it not taste this
way and I think what happens is is that
you have you have something like this
you know you people were attracted to
something that's over right and that
tastes like Jam in some ways and that's
not a bad way I think that's how I
started you know and and the fact of it
is is that you know as an Americans we
have a sweet palate right there's
nothing there's nothing wrong with that
we invented the cocktail during
Prohibition to cover up shitty booze we
like sweet these impressive dudes that
you date like trying to impress you with
like high-end Cabernet yes that's where
I learned it yes you nailed it like
honey
first half of this podcast now goes in
the garbage but I checked when you were
saying that I'm like oh I bet you
watering like the [ __ ] in like like like
I don't like heaven right behind you for
Tessa I was innocent space while you
were talking like oh that would be the
[ __ ] that Nate would pull you
like a boring Cabernet Travie I know you
wouldn't want a Cabernet you're super
bougie you wouldn't want some wine that
would confuse the girl she would leave
like while she went to the bathroom and
you'd be sitting there vivid in your
Gamay by yourself that's my first
favorite wine Trouty any girl on a date
definitely likes Rosie again no like
that literally is how its hit your radar
the Cabernet well yeah I mean like
that's how I learned about well wine
yeah you know my first boyfriend was
Swiss French and we for four years lived
in London and Paris he's much older than
you
no no interesting for years listed I
thought it was like you're you're like
he's not hoping for I was kinda looking
for like authority 54 your parents are
11 years apart yeah they're kickin it
going no all right why number three okay
smelling what do we let sniffing sniffs
what are you getting on the nose no this
is like this is like September New York
Fashion Week back into New York there
you go right now you're getting it all
the berries potpourri at my Grandmama's
house yeah no time in some person
shaving some ufi you can definitely
proud you can definitely say it's from
my leg or a mechanical pencil Utley you
but you go into smelling it expecting it
to be sweet
yeah right all right I get graphite on
then I get graphite today it's you know
what graphite also sometimes smells like
if you're going through it metallic like
it depends on how you articulate as an
ad you say yes but this almost smells
like you took an aluminum best when you
were like in Little League and you had a
bunch of strawberries and you started
smashing the strawberries and then you
smelled the baseball bat and the
stronger
chips no this is like you went on a
barbeque and someone gave you a piece of
pie to take home and aluminum and then
you opened it up that's like the normal
thing versus like the physical violent
way then you stop it but listen let's
not suppress Delta fresh clown yeah like
why are you suppressing my mail like
you're being way too politically correct
on me like why can't I be a boy for a
second I have to like I built Legos this
morning it's actually 11 a timebomb
material March no I don't like that
record this morning the Imperial March
so the reason this is playing is
mary-kate's boys do that with Alexa
every morning and walk around she
stopped because she said her name again
yeah Alexa stop so Erin what do you
think about this mine
um what do I think about it I think I
haven't tasted it yet well please taste
that Mary smells manly Erin's way behind
it she loved it I loved it it feels
balanced
this feels DeLuca and I want this one I
need to know what this is after yeah it
smelled amazing that's why I didn't stop
smelling it I think we just stay here
now for the rest today no I think I
think it's you know I'm too sweet for
you a little bit you're trying to figure
that it way that's coming from and you
know so in it and it's reduced right
it's like yeah what's all of that stuff
cooked it down and it's likes to its
crunchy that way like right yeah let's
say wine number three and we'll link
this and like when we post that this is
going to be I'm not sure what I think
about it you noticed that I also like it
I have you noticed how I asked Andre if
he thought it was too sweet it is a
little too sweet for me but I'm weirdly
in the mood for it to be sweet meaning
because we're in July I to me this is a
very intriguing barbecue wine it's like
as soon as I was drinking I was like ooh
you know like and like just easy like
exactly
um that's exactly right actually I also
like a mensch a coach if this is under
$20 and I've no idea what this says if
this is under $20 everybody who would
buy it what
[ __ ] love it oh yeah if it's under
$20 P Rawal will go bananas on them if
it's under $20 will you commit to buying
a case at Wine Library can many the cost
to full profit for me and my family
thank you thank you Mary Kay totally
your album a nearly editor-in-chief of
pure congratulations Gary well where
will you go you know it's you know I
mean I would look at it in probably like
don't baby my mighty one
okay nice range yeah I mean I like I
like this one
all right it's good what you said what
maybe not you won't want to party this
one just just pound it Mary Kay you can
throw up again you can you can bond I'm
glad that Kristin think it's like oh my
god you know what's funny I never ever
get hung over except the weirdest thing
I for some reason get drunk on sake I
don't know why the last seven times I've
been drunk have been eating at like high
ends like like like like Japanese like
sushi restaurant like 4:00 in the
morning and you've never been drunk I
don't drink that much I'm never drunk
because I always need to be in control
I've never done a drug in my entire life
like even though like my entire college
crew is all about smoking 14 blunts to
the face my dad's like I need to be in
control but the one thing that gets me I
don't know I don't see it coming I like
keep doing those little [ __ ] sake
shots
I never feel it then all of a sudden I
get in like my car to go home and like
the work like New York City goes upside
down on me and I'm like what the [ __ ]
so wine doesn't get you drunk I've never
I'm like I think it's the size of the
glass the sake like tricking me my
numbers maybe 15 more oh I understand
like this city hungover and my house so
do we have three little kids running
around so we always say hey are you
dehydrated you know that's so that's our
code word for being hungover
amongst the adults yes it's more like
hey there's nothing worse in life in
life than being hungover what
Andrea no okay Jesus well I'm just
asking you just say no but then the next
I mean so wait you're saying on the
repartee as we'd like to use this in it
like a piece of content that being hung
over is worse than murder
can we put that as official press
release on Purim do it okay good Erin
congratulations you don't like you don't
like this I don't like it no it smells
it smells like big Chicago farm girl oh
I'm just like you know like this is like
you you went to Iowa I'm not scared
you know no one wants to drink a fire I
prefer far over fruit only in my wine
earthy no this is super smartly and raw
mary-kate this smells like no
air-conditioning
New York City subway this is not Bo and
everybody knows what body odor smells
like this is not because fart this is a
[ __ ] how farm [ __ ] stepped into like a
pig [ __ ] is that stepped into it
bring up your booth it's like these
smells more to our yeah no Audrey can
you clean up this this where it gets
interesting now taste it it's great so
we farted in your face but now taste it
love you name for the podcast by the way
because okay I get it now I get why do
you taste you smell that and then you
taste right that was a story so what
Aaron necessary that you just can see
stepped in cows [ __ ] okay went to clean
the Buca farted on yes then you got four
Breeze men some like cherry its cherry
it's what I really know um we're on wine
number four
I Spit the other three I'm already fully
done drinking this glass this is amazing
do you love it yeah it freaks you out
that it could smell like this but tastes
like that is Oh Mary Kay it's amazing
really this is like throwing overalls a
little bit Oh boyfriend that farted on
you cuz he thought he was like a fratty
dude but you kind of were really into
because he was hot that's what this wine
is farted but it was delicious
that was never the life of these two
ladies that's why I'm trying to use my
empathy here the most serious wine
tasting in the world because you guys
like subscriptions on this podcast this
is the end of the Gary Vee audio
experience and Wine Library shut down
Andre you've been growing from zero to
forty thousand cases you're going back
to zero and Andre what do you thik the
wine I like that it's funky it's you
know it's it's not cookie cutter
there's like this p-funk sour cherry
great acidity in the wine not over oked
not oKed at all yeah so it just feels
just it feels natural
what kind of like what kind of grieve do
you think this is I know we haven't gone
down yeah you know I don't know maybe
climate like Cabernet Franc or something
like that I'm struggling with Trouty oh
you know here's what it is you know I
I'm struggling a little bit the floral
aspects of this wine are intriguing to
me like I literally I don't have a
frothy floral it could be a little bit
but to his point what's running through
my what he's probably thinking he
definitely doesn't think excuse me that
this is lawar Valley Cab Franc but he
could think it's new world Cab Franc and
if he's saying that right so like are
lawar go back actually now I'm recalling
cuz I'm a DD doubt domestic sparkling
wine what's happening you like that do
you rock that was like
juicing thing was like ten years ago
before when I was in it like gruel a
Mexico is happening there but now but
now you have his like now you are you
nerd do you have a property are you this
is your agenda
what's housing is you have more mobile
bottling lines that people are coming
around okay helping with that process a
good friend of mine just started a
company doing that but you just but you
just with you to see it now minute
domestic sparkling wine that's caught
the attention of the American consumer
recently whoa see I wouldn't say
consumer I'm on the underneath yeah I'm
on the greener the gatekeeper level
right what's caught the Nerds attention
absolutely rock means it's which is
sparkling who in the u.s. that freaked
me out I think people get bored and they
wanna that could mean that's actually
I'm sorry because I'm being selfish now
go ahead what's happening in the wine
scene in New York supplier wise
restaurant to our wives who's the
hottest sommelier in New York right now
I don't know you're at that game too
well that the fact of it is is this I'm
only here for the weekends week so well
okay so like who's killing it I think I
still think it like you know a lot of
some ways are coming into their own I
think there are more entrepreneurs are
more entrepreneurial than they ever have
been in in the past and I think and I
totally agree with you I think that like
just more people were more
entrepreneurial overall right so like so
I must still be like this like I'm doing
I need to I need to be enter this you
know this is fun that I'm doing this
then I need to reenter the game because
the truth is like you know when I did
Wine Library TV people thought I was a
douche bag at first and then they will
because it was so different cuz I'm a
little bit aggressive like I don't know
what was that this show was it for them
and that everybody thought it was for
you and the thing of it is is that and I
used to tell people grant it there's
gonna be some kid that's gonna come work
for you that got into wine from watching
this guy show it's just not for its like
like you can watch it for entertainment
value but like for everybody it's like
oh
like taman wine he's talking about wine
this way but all the younger kids are
gonna come like then there's people here
now in New York City who were running
wine programs that got into wine from
watching his show set and and like and
people got it all in a huff and a fuss
about it but that makes sense before
thousand seven yeah yes but that's ten
years ago that's before I was introduced
that's like the year that you know I was
started like moved to New York City and
you know it's like the art world that
feels uninviting it makes you feel
stupid which is like I mean I feel I'll
be honest I feel stupid today but you
know that's what it even still I've been
drinking wine and I know my I can I know
my way around one I know my favorites I
know like what is your favorites I mean
I am don't like own it oh I'm I'm just
I'm like four deep both nightmares
Village People I love I love natural
wines you do I love that that cloudy yep
unpredictable yeah I like the story like
if if I was a wine I'd be I would be a
natural wine yes favorite wine right now
or can yes beside after that a chill
very cold rose that anything I'm kidding
you're not a big wine person right no
I'm a huge mind person so I'll be like
if the teats are off but he's wrong yeah
very cool I mean something even drinking
some by myself I love sisters and we're
gonna leave right from here and get
tattoos the day Syrah sisters it will
never go 1129 a yeah
alright let's go what are you tell you a
second I have been really indignant Yolo
I'm on a Barolo like never neither
I had a 90 last night I had a 96 be a
single vineyard Barolo like I'm I think
Barolo is so under priced for what it
delivers
Burgundy what does it deliver when I
when I use that I use as a slang term
for what is the quality of that wine in
comparison to all the other wine what
are you tasting when you say quality
that's what people get that's what
people lose you cuz I don't know what
you mean I want to I want to know what
you mean so know you're a single person
that's thinking right now think about
the thing that you consume the most soda
hamburgers bourbon candy lemon gum like
for example Cola right for everybody 40
and older when we used to drink Cola
now all you kids drink water cuz you're
healthy and you all look great
especially with filters and angles on
Instagram so when we drink Cola it's so
easy for me to taste the difference
between coca-cola Pepsi RC Cola and Cola
that's private label shop right [ __ ]
right it's because I drank so much of it
like cupcakes I like them a lot
so it's super easy for me to like be
like oh this is a good cupcake this is a
[ __ ] cupcake but if it's the first
cupcake you ever had you don't have
context so everybody right now while
you're listening close your eyes and
think about the thing you consume the
most and now tell me in that category of
thing do you feel like you understand
what is good and what is not the answer
is yes
you have a very good sense that this
piece of pizza is good and this is not
this is this isn't that's how I think
about wine I consumed so much that I
have so much context that for my own
palate and I'm confident my own self
this is good wine this is not good wine
to me
Barolo is super interesting because it
has the nuances and characteristics and
complexity of Pinot Noir and burgandy's
but it has the fruit and the power of
the things that I like about Cabernets
and other varietals I think it's the
perfect meat middle end because the wine
critics don't carry as much weight
anymore nobody's able to make Barolo
super overpriced by giving everything a
hundred points like used to be able to
and so I think Barolo has found this
really sweet spot where it's not being
auctioned off in Hong Kong and you know
in these things I think it is the
perfect wine right now where if you buy
an $80 Barolo from a
really good producer I believe you're
buying a $400 burgundy Bordeaux or Colt
California wine and that's why I love it
well you heard it here there you go that
was good yeah you like that it's except
the lower super important set you were
looking at me a totally different way
you're like wait he knows other things
too that's what's happening with you
right now
iris okay good good all right let's get
into wine number five let's snippy snip
that soon we'll be like the bar really
looks like this is cute actually I might
have a little crush on you like Seth yes
dude a supermodel just said you're cute
this is the greatest this is the best
[ __ ] day in her life lately pictures
on Google take a screenshot text your
buddies would be like dude go to 54
minutes into podcast number one paper
bags like this is the great moment of
your life this might get cut this is Sal
oh no no you don't understand do you
understand anything that's like nothing
no Carrie I think about that all the
time
well Anne I like like literally every
day it's not editing thing that you do
cuz you you something about who you are
it makes me sit in question like okay
I'm not that like how come like why am i
with hope like it cuz that's a power you
know honestly that's the reason that I
became so attracted to you I think for
especially in your world I think you
were super unedited oh really
by comparison to your craft and the
other individuals I probably never say
they eat Dunkin Donuts right oh it's so
intense
oh really a real part I don't know how
to be different your purse yeah I'm a
real boy I just don't I don't know how
to be different but I get very I'm shy
so it's like I like if I'm told to even
for work take a video of myself and post
an entry I'm like that's gonna I can't
I'm like I don't know you you know let's
talk about that for a minute because
obviously you know reminded of like the
people that listen to this it's not
about wine a lot of them are it's about
getting us drunk nor did it and then
talk are you when you're so
most when you're being photographed like
are you like that is a strength of yours
oh well I was like you couldn't have had
the career you've had like active sport
when you're shy and I know you a little
bit so like when you're shy and real
like this that but when when it's game
time right like when you're in a
Victoria like you're shy yet Victoria's
Secret
like outfits are not shy type stuff when
the camera when the d-roc comes around
and you see that killer yeah I know that
sports it's really when I'm playing bass
like in the parameters of the rules what
you're doing if you put me in a space I
don't see anyone I can just move it's
like some people it's also jazz
musicians I think have this like I was
watching like I'm Kay guys it's the wine
but yeah that's the point it's like some
people have the creative outlet is their
physical person in time in space yeah
and it's it's kind of you can I can just
feel my bot like my body like whenever I
played whenever I was practicing if a
coach told me about what I did wrong
with my shot
you understood I could have I every time
I could immediately change it with him
just telling me I'm so attached to your
body yes something it's kinetic and so
that happens when I'm not involved with
like I'm just doing my thing but then
you make it I don't know I don't want to
film myself I understand you know it's a
completely different where you're like
if that's it for Aaron like that zone
what is your number
you're an entrepreneur you've built this
real business you've been a sommelier at
the high pressure cooker of Thomas
Keller restaurant but if you took it
your dad of three like in full life
where's your zone I think just in in
them in the moment with other people I
think this is still a people business
and that's why I get on the plane every
week to go to a place to meet these
people not so they can say that they
know me but more so I can say that I
know them and I think no one wants to do
business with an [ __ ] Yeah right you
like you like you generally want to like
those people when people give you money
you or invest in you or do different
things because they like you so resort
charisma kindness yeah I'm out on the
front lines in your office yeah we've
been able to back it I walk into a room
and start talking to people right away
we
and that wasn't always a strong suit I
mean I had though you developed to
figure that [ __ ] out right yeah
mary-kate story like I get doors I get
story I can you see something and you're
like oh that's like well you know in
space and you're like you can figure out
that I have an intial it's like what's
up what is this already business ready I
don't even look at stuff oh yeah you're
like a gangster no guys I know you're
listening
mary-kate is a gangster she's not even
looking at suitcase let me tell you
comics that are happening she's not
looking at Seth Seth is fairly read at
this point so just keep this going
go ahead Mary Kay okay um I wouldn't
know sass entire history in five minutes
I'm not getting like my husband all says
he's like you flirt with the world
because you ask everyone a thousand
questions you are very flirty but I have
you feel her flirtiness mary-kate is
one-of-a-kind seriously but no you guys
hung out in the HAMP's but go in a peer
out party it's one of you what happened
there did you make a significant okay
yeah yeah people yeah I love people say
I know much yeah yes you do nobody how
that's part of the charm I love people
so much I love their stories and I love
I can but I can do it from a business
sense like I can look at a proposal and
be like you lost the narrative here
you know I've been very impressed with
you I thought when I bump here Wow yeah
that I would fire you pretty quickly
scene yeah you thought you know good Joe
what's the first time we met mary-kate I
don't know maybe maybe in Austin not New
York
no in either can or Austin right maybe
three I was the first woman like we hung
out last like what was funny is no
because there's two cans ago yeah when I
already was negotiating did you you
didn't know yet Nidia three cans ago
three cans ago we hung out two ago ryan
told me right and this one we were
together yeah as a team dominating okay
your superpower this story this story I
don't know what that means how did you
get it right know what that means
we're our story that's like a noun
because I know but
I love I love story mound I'm terrible
at grammar I'm skilled but my skill set
is like telling narrative fun way I'm
sorry to interrupt you because I like to
do that yeah for everybody who's
listening right now for future brown-bag
episode I highly recommend
fast-forwarding the first basket the
fourth quarter is where all the [ __ ]
gets good go ahead Mary Kay I my dad was
a long time ad guy and I remember like
forever being like entranced with
commercials in 30 seconds telling this
like emotional too high of a story and
at the same time I was the biggest
reader and I remember staying in bed on
Saturday mornings I'm like all my
brothers and the youngest kid all my
brothers would be like the house would
be like vibrating I'm gonna link are all
four boys let's slide my mom a narrative
he was a reader too and I would stay in
bed and just like pummel through books
like chuck em aside and I just like Seth
story like I started as like his tats
like what those numbers mean and I would
what I mean so and then mary-kate family
junior did your are you close to your
mom closer okay did she like that you
got those tattoos why does she have any
tattoos do you have any other siblings
interesting yeah that was a moment what
are the numbers it's coordinates this oh
I was looking at Wikipedia last thing
I'm thinking why do they put the
coordinates on you're like who is
looking at this [ __ ] set you guys
talk about this later over a bottle of
Cabernet some all right wine number five
yes sippy-sip
I already drank it
what do we got Andre back smells a
little bit soapy potpourri aromatic so
he always says potpourri
so it's listen to police Tootie's to his
defense potpourri is easily the one
there's so much floral aspects to wine
that whether you associate with properiy
whether you stop so see irregular hours
the tree is like dusty and hard and
crackly where floral is like blue or
line is this this is where the way you
describe things matter go ahead and but
what happens is is that it gives off
it's a more potent it more more
fabricated like perfume or and that's
what I'm talking about going here not
when I say floor yeah I do recognize
something soft and maybe more natural
this doesn't even though it just it
doesn't it reminds me definitely of like
potpourri and we don't break it down any
Aaron favorite social network social
network your favorite app oh well
definitely Twitter really yeah I love I
mean I love comedians writers you know
what to talk about your Twitter the
first time we engaged was on Twitter I
need everyone on Twitter
that's crazy about that is your Twitter
profile picture I thought this is not a
joke funny thing to say when you engage
with a piece of my content and I'm like
seeing it like as I do I thought you
were a media company like you have like
some we what is your picture on Twitter
right now it was it was after the
election I don't know I hadn't slept I
don't know it's like a woman holding a
flower remember is like it no the back
you have to see I was like a stream
account likes my content that's cool I
would love the who's this person and
then I googled I'm like what I know I'm
gonna fix it I just I would definitely
not put this weird [ __ ] book watching
your Twitter so what you do in news is
too much you know it's just sleeping you
know so Twitter's your favorite contract
Instagram yeah you've been doing damage
on Instagram I've been watching you from
you know it's funny that we're doing
this together we uh we haven't talked in
a long time a long time um and we used
to hang out quite a bit the base of my
hangouts you guys know
what happened I know this is an
intervention I got married at a diner Oh
and the ball dropped Sooey signed it we
got married in a diner signed the
certificate at midnight we toasted with
chocolate shakes and we went to Gary's
house for a party and the ball dropped
you better celebrate it with us and then
we had like a cliche honeymoon is it
weird to ask what monopoly monopoly crap
my life is an art competition
oh absolutely all I'm thinking about
right now is everybody's listening I'm
like they better like me the most of
these four people like so so so you've
done a really good job like for me it's
really been fun because I feel like I
feel like in a lot of ways you've picked
up a torch that I lacked
dude I listen to you so this dude shows
up to my house for a blind tasting so we
have all these people come in here ings
the doorbell he shows up and he's got a
bottle of Barolo in one hand and he's
got a bottle of Cristal in the other
hand and he's at the front door and I'm
like dude it's a blind tasting so we're
like okay so then we call to the store
and we're like hey we're doing a blind
tasting at the house this is the budget
can you brown bag all the wines and
bring them over and so while we're
waiting he says hey is this your laptop
we're in my kitchen and he flips it open
he starts [ __ ] typing and [ __ ] on it
and I'm like blown away like first and
foremost what retail wine dude has five
IT guys like I just couldn't understand
that like I was like there's a lettuce
know something that I don't know and
then you flipped open the computer and
you're like show me all the people who
had visit the site right and talk about
like Wine Library these with all they
hit so I'm getting and I was like I
should probably pay attention to this
dude and it's you know I'm on Twitter
because you said be on Twitter I
remember right and you're like dude no
no that's like I'm on it what the [ __ ]
am I supposed to be doing it's like join
the conversation hashtag delicious so I
you know I take a lot of lead of seeing
what you guys have doing what you guys
have been doing and
trying to apply it in in my field in my
world and you know it's it's it's been
fun to experiment you know that I mean
to be honest that's you know that's
that's what keeps it fresh and new for
me
right because getting on the road and
going to see people that's really fun
but like you talking and and the people
that you pick up along the way that
follow you and and you get it people you
know you're not that you're not the kid
from you know what I mean like you're
the wine guy to a lot of the wine people
you were this wine guy that was in New
Jersey but to thousands and millions of
people you became you became an
inspiration to those people and the
people back there didn't understand they
can't they can't get it you know you
know yeah yeah I mean like I think that
you make all the like I think all the
social networks need someone that make
it look positive and interesting and
inspiring and like highbrow and
something like just no one else is doing
that like that this has become my
favorite part of the crowd II my man I
think I want to know what your favorite
social network is Mary Kay a thousand
percent Instagram thousand percent us
one thousand percent water why it's the
perfect mix of everything of everything
set that's right
trout Nate boys are visionary size in
Mary Kate you do your own thing
wow what a dominance work I totally
believe it and I feel like now that I've
embraced stories a little bit cuz I
didn't really [ __ ] what snapchat yeah
but it reminds that gives me the the
broadcast yeah kind of element that you
would associate with Twitter right why
number five what do we got Mary Kate
just really moved by today so far it's
almost noon I just cancel my day guys
we're all going to my house
the theme of this should be I can't feel
my face music the weekend will be on
episode 2 we all miss Amon no sir I like
this I guess I would nosy nosy all right
it's boring
Andre it is brand cranberry that's kind
of blah I don't think that it isn't it
doesn't move me in a certain way you
know and I feel like it's a little a
little bit on the acidic side it was
acidic okay
back at the throat no yeah and then you
you accentuate acidity on the sides of
your tongue so if you yeah yeah so if
you start to salivate or like the sides
of your tongue start to tingle that
means the wine I drink wine
second-to-last
noir yeah yeah farts McGee number one I
have to go with number one because my
entire view and excuses for anything
right win back to the routine or three
again I'm just thirsty wine mary-kate
you're holding up the show it's already
hung an hour plus we're gonna see the
length of this and be like [ __ ] that
it's either two or four - that's nice
which one's your favorite wine okay
mine's for as well okay so four so let's
let you say the word I've been yeah so
Andre nice war um let's start with wine
number five we just had it yeah and
let's see what it is trout you ready
good wine number five
all right we're unveiling that's the big
part of the show and we're gonna like so
they give us a drum line number five
Maday go Ridge Pinot Noir from Santa
Cruz I mean I liked it the Pinot I knew
it was you think so either right $47.99
which is about $40 too much 93 points
Parker I think he's losing his stats I
loved it I don't know that's about it
Santa Cruz is in I was how do the points
work them so there's a let's get 100
points yeah it's kind of like
scale hundred point scale everything
that's 90 and above tends to get
people's attention 89 is like The
Scarlet Letter
like it's so [ __ ] [ __ ] up if you
get an 89 point score
nobody wants you yet like it's
completely subjective in a 90 everybody
wants you get 90 you blow up yeah it's
like being second for the covers like
b-plus student man yeah all right that
was wildly I really liked it and blown
away that Parker would score that 93
points it's not his normal kind of jam
no maybe he wasn't like we're unknowing
Parker's palate Oh Jeb donek who's by
the way I'm a big fan of that makes it a
little bit more understanding but I
still don't agree with Jeff I'm like
Parker you have you Interactive's man
yeah he's in school Robert I might be
was a legend but I mean the thing is
like why be mad at him because
everybody's always gangster yeah
everybody follow me you know what he was
the most powerful wine critic he was a
lawyer from Maryland and I thought he
was unbelievably humble for his power
and the only people that hated him is
when they when he reviewed their wine
poorly and I have a lot of admiration
for him and what I earlier said five
seconds ago I built my career on him I
mean that because once I understood what
he liked I was able you know how you
said you were in tune with your body I'm
super in tune with a lot of things
actually which is why I think I've done
well and I was able to literally go
backwards reverse engineer his palette
and over a course of like five to eight
years got to a place where whether I
agreed with him or not I had a good
intuition on how he would think about
that wine and that serviced me well
because I would make bets by hundreds
and hundreds of cases of wine that would
always fit this criteria I liked it and
I thought he would score it well and I
ended up being the person that had all
the wine when four months later in the
advocate scores get an item five point
cord coming that's like an intuition
thing above it was like yeah I'm gonna
go with this guy and I know what he's
gonna like that's it for tonight like
number four you were a number two girl
you're a number one girl so number three
the one that we didn't like number - oh
yeah number two Cup beat up pretty cool
number
get up pretty good okay Envy wines
Cabernet Calistoga State 2014 $55 $55
for tea okay 48 99 5
Oh what a steal now you want Parker whap
this time Parker Parker we didn't agree
yeah we just not agree on the show all
right
one two four okay so we're gonna unveil
number one first
all right here this is your wine I think
I'm at this is your wine you look at you
Andre thank you air dry flavor in the
brown bag for you to take this is back
maybe yeah we're just you do right as
well
Wow Genaro Milan yeah it's a pretty good
ship is expensive 90 points Jeb donek
fixed well actually I do you go fudge no
no no you shouldn't be disappointed that
you're under $20 girl you should be
pumped they know I'm everything I'm I'm
under $20 bill without 16 bucks bro I
just don't like that bougie stuff it
always Travis me round' way alright why
number two this is your wine
mary-kate you ready take the cote de
blanc right like that I wouldn't have a
wine is this it's and this was a white
Burgundy had it right yep no general
[ __ ] do you know this pressure I
don't know the preserve smaller gets the
beans Janelle
Bowl NJ shosanna Montrachet Premier Cru
2014
single vineyard Labor's in it we got 91
Wine Spectator $90 big shout out to mr.
bored we both love who's that 90 bucks
really awesome do has to be the head of
used to be exact ease that he was the
head of what crew which is a big time
and now he's got a bunch of restaurants
your new business him yeah Bernie
started this company Charlie burger you
know Charlie bird right the restaurant
yes that's in them 90 bucks
please don't cut me you feel so good
right high-class lady alright mr. Matt
you and I know I mean we agreed which
puts extra pressure on us because I'm so
curious like this [ __ ]
Oh talk about it yeah tangent hair one
of the greatest stop oh my god your face
he's very lucky think you just saw your
like Shia understand why we're proud
this is a good this was double-blind we
knew nothing and you understand for us
there were bigger stakes here which is
we'd like to be proud of was like one of
the greatest ones of France grounds
repair it's 2012 and I haven't had this
wine in years
Wow it was great seeing you know mr.
Crowley getting this $5 totally unrated
it's a cold wine yeah doesn't score it
yeah what's the great breakdown - you
know what a commercial all I'm actually
at a poor but I have more - 43 % 40%
Syrah what 40 words that move at the 20%
is a balance it feels great that move
Edra great great and 20% feel grapes
okay Andre I'm pretty happy with myself
here I expect to like have some bad
episode of brown bags but I think we
drilled this one that was crying it's
all game I said if it was 20 bucks to be
good yeah guys that didn't work out with
good news a couple of viewer ballers so
instead of buying it on the [ __ ]
watch or a Lamborghini
buy a case of this wine take me out for
dinner I'm cheap
no Aaron you're $16 this 105 they can
take you know that's my seven-day to the
Aaron [ __ ] Sal you're still young in
your career great news I can afford the
supermodel
let's wrap it up mr. Mack what do you
got to say good first art do you feel
the way I do which is there's a good
chance that in your Wikipedia entry
being a guest on Episode one of brown
bags may that we're on to something here
yes it's gonna change my life oh my god
I don't even know where I am I feel like
I found three new best friends today and
what we weren't friends before no best
you fell so I love you guys I love wine
and I am so excited for this to be the
only episode of this show we'll start
with you and go the other way
I love culture hacking us what's
happening culture right now that has
your attention let's end the great
that's a great way to end with is our
new thing I just paid up on a side I
have to think I understand it's all it's
all in my ear it's like we've all been
walking around with earphones and beads
and pods and whatnot for the past couple
years but now it's cerebral and smart
and podcasts and like it's ridiculously
dope with jay-z's new album it's just
being open to album I I'm it's on repeat
I love it so much and then it's Alexa
like him come admitting that Becky all
of it like tell me that he was a bad guy
really makes him a great guy explain
this to me from up it's yeah it's it's
is we're Fame just lets you do anything
well no I've already feeling that obsess
admitted that he cheated on Erin that
she's like this is a great guy well I
heard this week being like okay if you
cheated I'd be like no thanks save my
time
it's like it's like Donald Trump jr.
being like here the emails that show
that there's collusion like it's it's no
it doesn't work so in your ear is what's
Muslims in my ear it's all happening
it's awesome you agree with me that
voice sound a thousand percent I see the
three year old Charlie asking Alexa to
play Imperial March playing period 7th
time today by John C Williams Karen do
with the rights to the song okay you're
finished what do you mean a culture what
is happening in the world that has your
attention just standard comedy stand-up
comic sit down alright comedy dude
that's my buddy that's all I do you do
stand-up comic nah no no I just consume
it that who are they interested in now I
mean I've watched everything I Netflix
and I learned something about myself
it's pretty watch have you watched
Chappelle stand-ups part yeah I wanted
terrorist yeah yeah okay fair calm no
I'm like deep deep and comedy like I've
been watching comments knows a little
kid like that's my one who's your
favorite stand-up comedian of all time
louis c.k obviously but he lived in my
apartment before me get his mail and I'd
even joke that's the yes amazing thought
this so what is your favorite all-time
comedian it's funny cuz I just watching
the flight the documentary on misery
loves comedy course but [ __ ] I can I
like how you're buying time who's your
favorite all-time comedian I mean stand
up stand up i if you had to prom or I'll
go Richard Pryor for me mr. Mack was
really yeah and for you okay I don't
want to sound they're good like the girl
who picked the you know ii was expensive
wine here but I feel like Seinfeld did
something to make comedy like very
accessible very much but but I don't
love it Santa
Jeff you're sorry absolutely at up where
was he
yeah poor side where was he yeah I go to
comedy slap myself all the time that's
like my hobby best friend should be
there how would you know what's that
Seth what are you taking Aaron which
comedy club are you in there and going
to on your first date culture culture
having lots of different things that
piqued my interest obviously from a wine
standpoint you know I I really feel like
athletes and you know people who looked
like me that whole genre black folks
don't really drink wine let's just put
it out there you know it's been it's not
again obviously this is audio Andres
black so like I'm excited to see that
you know LeBron James just did this
whole video them in the barbershop Steve
Stoute shows it with 90 Latour so that
loves wine so I'm like what are you
doing alright I think it's cool because
what happens is we we live in a world
war know Weezy Texas you and said
already had that meeting you did yeah
well let's wait a minute let's wait we
already had that meeting but they they
it's so much heard me in there attorneys
from Capitol Records that were there but
but all from a business standpoint you
were great about doing a JV with we were
doing something with them but the same
reason why you left is the same reason
why they're like [ __ ] dude like it's so
much aiming it's easier to ship toxic
waste in this country who leaves a ship
a case of wine literally guys you can
buy a grenade online easier didn't buy
when they relax like it you know what
we're in the books with this in a
totally different way take a step back
yes Wayne is like the best lovin were
you like losing your mind that you were
there no you know dude I've met people
before yeah like you know how it is
though like like of course you've met
cool people before I even Aaron but like
yeah I mean I know I had no idea and now
culturally you know what I mean like
let's just talk about it like you know
Blackwell to lure the folks in drink
tequila no right t-pain and Usher's
start talking about patron and next
thing you know they're back ordered in
New York you know something that's
considered leaven what yes very clear
hip-hop yeah is the foundation of
culture yeah like that is very clear in
20 so we all watch the Defiant ones yep
it's amazing mean it change I'm only
listening to Snoop Dogg right now
damn love sir that's new yeah the case
was listen to music pre 2004 work before
everything got ut2004 everything sucks
everything sucked at Drake in the
weekend I don't know I'm not a hater
what you just said they suck no no but
there's something about it's just like
smell is the strongest connection to
your memories 2004 is the strongest
connection it's just something about
listening to music that's fair amazing
love who's your favorite John Mayer who
I was with last night
yeah and then the other thing is that
I'm big on voice I've been on voice
dictation for the last four years I
answer all my emails that way I'm
reading that right new book that way my
kids know how to do it they can't even
spell [ __ ] but they know the double tap
to FN key on the computer and then they
say what they want right do you still
have that Bone Thugs bone T surely can
you send me one I don't rock sure yeah
what is it again what does the same just
says Bone Thugs in Burgundy right
because guys for everybody's watching
bone is like this region in France good
and so that's the way he smells it's I
love Bone Thugs and so when I saw that
like I love that smell
tells that culturally like I'm excited
for a lot of like what technology is
like put us you know I showed up to New
York and like nobody in the wine
business had a blackberry everybody made
fun of me in the restaurant because I
always had headphones on everyone liked
my parting gift when I left uno seven
was Bose headphones right because
everybody just thought that was funny
and then you know and then you know and
in the year or two later everybody's
walking around everybody has headphones
on right do you be fun of them now like
you see them no no no I just kind of let
it let it be known you know think is
your auditory that's why you speak your
that's where your veer towards yeah I
mean it's it's just so much easier like
you know my whole thing is like I want
to write this book
100% voice dictation that's just a part
memoir part wine book so part by the way
my life and part about by the way
Andres wife wrote an ink I want to know
who she is I didn't want to be see about
it so [ __ ] bad-ass she's the real
[ __ ] do you know like you say like this
kid right yeah how much you like him
right now right and the racist kids
really a piece of [ __ ] compared to those
absolutely yeah he sucks like huge
mistake having him here what's Phoebe's
thing man she is so the thing that I
most love about myself is that I don't
waver I'm being serious
I do not wait I appreciate that you does
not waver like when I think of the
people I've met in my life in my life
and this was a period time from two
thousand six seven eight when we would
hang out a bunch like Phoebe does not
waver I respect the [ __ ] out of it yeah
she just she's who she is like that's a
great qualities like no no Trouty you
ever noticed yeah
you know perfect weight in this show
guys thank you so much
Andre Aaron Mary Kate thank you fine guy
pioneers I love you guys Linc you uh
make sure everybody in the vaynernation
knows who are guys like you lit for
listening to brown bags one will decide
to leave a comment with your favorite
part of the episode who said the
funniest thing what was the most fun
leave your three cents see
[Music]